in the battle against coronavirus this
is the body armor but shortages mean
medics are being asked to reuse some of
their disposable protective gear public
health England is even recommending
plastic aprons
if gowns are unavailable one NHS worker
at an intensive care unit in London told
us of his concerns as stocks run out he
wanted to remain anonymous you can't say
to people for this amount of time these
gowns are disposable and then the next
day say Oh actually we've changed our
mind that's the difficulty if they'd
said from the very beginning we can
safely reuse equipments then it wouldn't
be a problem the problem is that it is
constantly changing because it is very
much reliant on the stock not the
evidence as well as suspicions there's
anger at perceived failings in the
supply chain and its impact on the NHS
frontline staff will have to make
difficult decisions awful decisions
about whether they are able to continue
caring the new advice gives us if you
like you know bronze-level
adequacy and second best in this
situation is just not good enough
ministers and officials accept it's a
challenge but they're facing criticism
more isn't being done to source
equipment from local suppliers why is
there such a national shortage is it a
failure to to stockpile in the first
place is it a failure of the supply
chain to buy and distribute efficiently
the government does stockpile PPE for
pandemics and that has been incredibly
important and useful in our response to
this but as you hinted at this is a
global crisis a global emergency and
there is undoubtedly a strain on supply
chains for PPE the demand for certain
items of personal protective equipment
has increased 5,000 percent since the
pandemic started this week a plane load
of supplies arrived in the UK
from Shanghai the gravest shortage is in
clinical gowns and China is the only
immediate bulk source but there's
massive global competition for
protective gear and it's causing delays
with orders once stock arrives in the UK
it must pass a safety test something
that's not always guaranteed they were
ordered a month ago that the
consignments are coming in fits and
starts and sometimes when they are
arriving they are either not what was
ordered by e their masks instead of
gowns for example or they aren't passing
the stringent quality tests that are
required in this country china isn't the
only answer turkey too has airlifted
supplies and will deliver more tomorrow
including 400,000 gowns
it's the equivalent of what the NHS goes
through in two to three days
just-in-time PPE not a long-term
solution
Deborah Haynes Sky News